out there and he spelled it out he's not
hiding it he's out there wrecking up
mining that's what he said that's what
I'd like to know how does he feel the
guy said if the guys leave the high body
count and you haven't let him answer yet
and I'd like him to answer how do I feel
I think um it comes down to listen the
girl wants to wrap up numbers that's up
to hers her body her choice I don't I
don't give up no I'm not talking about
if a woman I'm talking about
who said that eventually you'd like to
say oh that I'm talking about what is
the highest body count that you would
accept for your future
don't ask the question no no last
question I guess uh answer numbers are
subjective so if someone could think 10
is high someone could think a hundreds
high this is all subjective but I
depends on the person listen I would
like a number a number what do you want
I would like single digits single digits
single digits okay